boss how big is your hands can you put  your hands here like your fingers those  are your fingers are long yeah you got  some yeah so it's interesting your  fingers are super long yeah but then  this part of your hand Palm is small  fingers are long yeah so it's good for a  grip because you can go around very  interesting yeah yeah did you did you  did you see that I see how big his hands  are yes but no but but this is this part  is small the fingers are long so you can  grip I always do oh my God please  size that middle finger  don't take this personally oh my God one  more time please that is the longest  middle finger this is kind of E.T over  here  I just noticed that right now wait a  minute what was that all about